hello everybody and thanks for coming
hey everybody big friend out here today
free podcast
that's my announcer voice hey everybody
and someone's just your voice no this
it's not that different Happy
Thanksgiving
so thankful for you all joining us here
today you know we pulled into the
parking lot and there was nobody there
and I was like holy [ __ ]
it was difficult I'm telling you it was
difficult to come in today I had a
big-ass meal I could barely move but we
did it we came in we did it so thank so
god bless today's episode is sponsored
by post mates Dollar Shave Club and
Vince arrow how was all of your
Thanksgiving how was your Thanksgiving
you it was nice
luckily you made I don't food yeah so I
enjoyed some food but I don't like the
Thanksgiving food you know what can I
make a confession
I don't like Turkey it's the most boring
yeah
meat imaginable mmm it's gaming it's dry
usually it's just it's not there it's
just no it's not a word of the bird with
the cranberry cranberry what what I know
there's people at home who were like oh
yeah I know it's a very polarizing dish
yeah I don't like stuffing I don't like
cranberry I don't like Turkey but I took
Thanksgiving it to my own hands because
I said you know what I'm gonna make a
pot roast and I like to call these
Ethan's heavenly potatoes true
because I want to make sure you look
could eat and what Ethan's heavenly
mashed potatoes look and I'll let me
tell you okay I'll tell you what's in it
but that doesn't do you any good cuz
it's all about the technique when people
see what's in it they can't believe that
it's gonna taste good well sure and you
should be you should be horrified about
what I put in it but that's the secret
to every good restaurants cook
you know what I mean is that's why I
food at restaurants tastes so
unbelievably good it's because if you
actually went back there in the kitchen
you would never have the balls to cook
food the way they do like you know
putting a whole stick of butter and for
like two eggs scrambled eggs you're like
oh these scrambled eggs are amazing I
never had my eggs never taste like this
before there's a whole stick of butter
so what I do is I put a whole stick of
butter and a whole block of cream cheese
for every four potatoes so yesterday was
- yeah there was eight potatoes two
whole sticks of butter and two whole
blocks of cream cheese and I hear Danny
freaking out in the back but I'm telling
that sounds mom it is bomb Dan but you
know it no it doesn't it tastes airy it
tastes light it tastes incredible you
can eat hamp mouthfuls and mouthfuls and
little do you know that every bite has
probably 200 calories I love that mashed
potatoes the best dish ever like
potatoes by themselves are already
pretty unhealthy but then you like or
like heavy heavy let's say yeah there's
just nothing really good in it I guess
but it's not I know no I'm not a
nutritionist I'm not even gonna claim
that I don't make claims on this podcast
anymore yeah I don't what's funny I
don't even know that my name is Ethan I
cannot confirm or deny that my name is
Ethan allegedly allegedly my name is
Ethan and it was Thanksgiving yesterday
don't hold me to that though
incoming exposed videos about my name
not be anyway these potatoes are
incredible or a hit I got this pressure
cooker instant pot have you guys heard
of this whole crazy night I had two
massive pot roast I put in there for two
hours
mmm I gotta tell you nobody cared about
the turkey I had a pity bite just so my
sister didn't feel bad your sister
cooked all day that turkey I know and
that's what I'm saying you came in two
hours I pop it in I set it and forget it
and all of a sudden it's smashed potato
heaven I I care so much about smashed
potatoes
smash mashed potatoes and it's so
important that they be right you know I
don't all day but at any rate I hope you
dan how was your Thanksgiving it was
great it was really nice actually saw a
bunch of extended family I haven't seen
in years so that's cool and nice good
food you're vegetarian were they able to
accommodate you they did accommodate it
was very nice of them the the wife of my
uncle I guess my aunt in-law if that's
the thing she's a vegetarian too so she
hooked it up so thank you to that show
what Harold what are the vegetarian eat
on Thanksgiving well I mean most of the
sides are vegetarian and they they made
sure the like the stuffing
you know usually the stuffing isn't
vegetarian but they made vegetarian
stuffing and you know the cranberries
and I know you I know how you feel about
the Christmas and in and Zach everyone
had a good time everyone's happy
everyone's satisfied I hope I mean I'm
not a big fan of Turkey either but who
is no I mean some people like it we're
also not fans of the pies so there was a
bunch of pumpkin pie and I don't I can
you know I don't want to offend too many
people here I know I'm gonna start a
whole new wave of but I don't like
pumpkin pie but we ate and he made a
chocolate pie thank God for that well at
any rate listen um but enough of that
I'm glad everyone had a Happy
Thanksgiving and I'm glad you're here
Black Friday as you all know let's get
to the real business which is today
right Jay's Black Friday oh yeah good I
gotta appreciate this like it's so
amazing how the sandwich and then like
first of all you got this beautiful
thick ass and then even the hand in the
top right it's just incredible I
actually had an awkward moment with this
because I was looking at my phone at
Thanksgiving and so you tweet this and I
started laughing my ass off in my famiiy
deity my family what are you laughing at
what are you looking at like I was like
I don't really want to show you this do
you consider
my boss there you go you consider this
open-faced sandwich not-safe-for-work
Dan yeah that's why I was like to be
honest it's a little lewd but I have to
be that might have to be switched and
I'll say forward very gross to you naked
except my balls dripped down at the
bottom of that toast James Baldwin
you're your legend dude you can see why
illa likes me so today's Black Friday
and there's a tradition in America to
stomp the face of every grandma in the
way of your new ps4 but I have to say
this year we had a mellow a mellow year
I didn't see any fights I didn't see any
babies thrown across Walmart I didn't
see any ambulances picking up 90 year
olds nothing like that I think the
stores have finally gotten smart it's
more like that all the videos are
surfacing again yeah cause people are
craving those yeah I noticed that yeah
there's all these slick guys on YouTube
just they re uploaded all the old [ __ ]
and they say Thanksgiving Black Friday
fight 2018 and disable all the comments
and then every year but there's no
really juicy fresh fight memes I think
enough people died and got trampled when
I watch those old videos I'm like my god
how did they not they you need to have
order in your store but what we did find
was some friend so what I've got here is
a little segment called Black Friday
around the world yes
here we go I've got USA Canada and
Brazil how do you think this will go
let's start in the United States and see
what Black Friday is like there this one
I couldn't tell if it was from this year
because there's so
again people are so started pretty calm
exactly excuse me
it heats up doesn't it look like a
nightmare
it just blows my mind imagine waking up
at 3:00 a.m. - I mean we tried once
number though we're gonna make it I mean
this is your day off this is
Thanksgiving Day and you spend your day
at 3:00 a.m. trying to save so you can
find most of the cells online no yeah
you don't need okay I don't know some
places do these crazy in-person deals
but it's like they're trying to start a
riot yeah you know yeah you got it
we need to order Walmart but we're
supposed to play the theme song yeah you
got to hit me with that Zach Zach no the
Walmart theme song oh yeah hey throw it
up now
for audio listeners there's just swords
of people grabbing television and say oh
it's nearly in a riot here of people
jumping over escalators and grabbing
television wonders I mean there you have
it there you have it so that is black
fright you want to watch that do you on
yeah not like we have anything better to
do we are we are Walmart yes sir one
with lyrics oh you serious and when you
typed it I love that so I guess a
manager at Walmart wanted to do a little
hype video for their people they get
excited for Black Friday I think it was
the day up yeah has the best this guy's
employer this century nobody gets paid
enough to do this now [ __ ] kill
myself
[Music]
they just gave this they just gave this
guy 25 cent raise he's all state did he
say you got blood on your wait why do
you have blood on your face is that what
Black Friday is for them oh you're gonna
be a cashier someday whoa really dream
dream big ela you're gonna be a cashier
someday yeah you got blood on your face
you love this place really because those
images seem contrary you'll be a thing
we need the one with the lyrics you're
right we need this decoded what's that
one uh what's that one YouTube channel
that decodes lyrics genius yeah genius
the one you need a genius on Walmart
fight song analysis you you may be a
cashier someday if you play your cards
right at Walmart
[Music]
two more times give them a break I think
this guy's doing it slowly for himself
be sure this constitutes bro unusual
punishment Constitution under the United
States law I love that great so here you
have it Black Friday and America god
bless these wonderful country here we
have Black Friday and Canada they're
getting a round of applause
best five it looks like congratulations
on wasting your holiday well they're
Canadians look how wonderful this is it
probably took coffee they're just
walking in super orderly and calm
employees are lined up and putting
around books giving high-fives kind of a
fog watch what if what a joy what a
drill what a thrill you know does think
when I was watching that it just takes
one lunatic to start running and it sets
off that chain reaction cuz I know well
I think if one person from the bottom
started cutting and running a front
that's it full riot mode in America
you've got five of those from the
beginning and nobody ever had a chance
ok but there you have it Black Friday in
Canada and now finally as you all know
Brazil is as a crime-ridden country
there's huge disparities of very rich
and very poor lots of corruption it's a
rough place so Black Friday and Brazil
as you can imagine is gonna be one of
the craziest things you ever see
and so I warn people with young children
and who are sensitive to trigger
warnings to divert their eyes from this
very graphic scene Black Friday in
Brazil but I see you
they got the mascot some girl with I
don't know bouillon yeah yeah so they're
all the employees are lined up at the
gate and they're about to start pounding
it to get everyone outside super
heightens here we go they got a DJ by
the sound of it the pounding on the wall
get ready everybody
completely empty there's not a single
person outside not even one single
person outside nobody's there incredible
I wonder how they miscalculated that one
yeah we're gonna get demonetized for
sure I find it fascinating that nobody
peeked outside I love how they're
pounding on the gate there's got a DJ in
the mascot not even one person got the
memo not even one person so there you
have it and Lou of anything interesting
to talk about this Black Friday Black
Friday around the world and on the topic
of Thanksgiving we are a very topical
show if nothing else Barney at the
Thanksgiving Day Parade nice Macy's
Thanksgiving Day Parade excuse me thank
you in 1997 was murdered this is Elaine
gunned down by the New York State Police
and we talked a lot here on the show
about police brutality well this is
police brutality the worst I've seen in
a long long time
so this is more of a memorial for Barney
this is amazing actually so it was
really windy winter day and the Barney
flow just it just gets so out of hand
this video reminds me of Gulliver's
traveled and
little people laugh at him oh yeah the
Rope over them and they're trying to
take them out
[Applause]
I think this is probably the most go
well the people on the ground well so
Barney's floating everywhere he's
completely out of control and people on
the ground are wrestling it's almost
like a dragon I feel like I'm watching a
mythological battle I'm trying to like
well of mythical beast you skip to where
it gets real spicy the crowd is a
balloon as they should be the sooner
you can see people all whoa why is that
rope the link everyone's dressed up at
it's a bunch of young I thought they
were a lady but they're just up is like
gnomes or something what are you gonna
hang it on picture even literally got
people just as gnomes clinging on to
ropes for dear life I mean it's
incredible but this is the site of
Santa's workshop that we have not seen
before
it just is Barney yeah Barney's Barn
Barney's molding Barney people I thought
they were known Stan why can't they be
gnomes there could be no oh and so I
wonder if you would get me and then it
splits a wide open under the gust of
wind they fighting to quell the Beast
you're like a five-year-old you love
Barney I mean the audience is losing
their mind because this is the most
exciting thing they've ever seen in
Thanksgiving Day Parade you think you
could get taken out if that thing just
tumbled into the crowd
its massive probably yes sir they fill
those up with helium is that what they
do to make them float yeah cuz is in
helium like a precious resource that's
like a lot of helium that precious I've
heard that it's a finite resource that
cannot be replenished so it's a good
thing we're using it for important
things Barney this is when it gets
really violent and again I have to give
a trigger warning here for people
we're sensitive the violent content
because as you're about to see the boys
in black the police are about to make a
violent slaying of this innocent
bystander
I mean what did Barney ever do except
try to entertain the kids and here he is
being gunned down taken down in cold
blood I mean he's just a brother trying
to live his life you know what I mean
just trying to enjoy the parade gotta
bring the dinosaur down humans always
keeping the dinosaur down I mean God
there's no justice in this world you
know we need some human rights activist
take a look at this foot yes his body is
splitting apart yeah if you're a Barney
lover this has got to be some traumatic
footage yeah here come the police guys
so again sensitive warning here
here they come at the foot they starting
to stab him at the feet please oh this
is a griddle I got to commend these
brave officers honestly climb on top of
that with a knife it's pretty daunting
Oh crazy doesn't this remind you of
Gulliver travels like it seriously feels
like they're bringing down a dragon or
some [ __ ] it's kind of mythical you're
right yeah and on the day of November
22nd 1997 the dragon was slain they
decapitating him look out there but
again and they're Gabba day to go
where's Jesse Ventura brutal brutal
party yeah so that was exciting I had
never seen that before kind of a thrill
kind of a joy on this beautiful
Thanksgiving Day you know what do you
know about Thanksgiving cuz you are an
immigrant to this country you know
nothing Turkey oh you say thanks I think
that's probably what most people know
about it you know we never said thanks
at dinner that's true
should we do it now no to be exciting
what am i thankful for what am i truly
thankful for well clearly you mmm
clearly I'm thankful for you everything
good in my life was a result of I'm
thankful for this is so what it's great
to know not good content I have Black
Friday deals day you might be thankful
for how he was trying to say way out of
this okay let's do that so go ahead you
look put together segments for us I mean
how exciting is this
oh [ __ ]
it's 3:30 if we take a break or you want
to do this segment first yeah okay so
when we come back from our break ela a
splits
their Black Friday deals that nobody
wants and there's some hilarious stuff
on here like the Dollar Tree
everything's $1.00 today only and so
much more today on the h3 podcast
Thanksgiving extravaganza uh as usual
your stomach and the rest of your life
are at war you need to eat but you can't
stop what you're doing to deal with it
and the only fast things that deliver
are not what you want I've had this
problem all the time your favorite
restaurant doesn't deliver well now they
do with posts mates yes the app that
adds a delivery option to your favorite
restaurants but that's not all you
forgot eggs milk no problem
they'll go to the grocery store you want
that tasty burger from your favorite
place
no problem they'll go there even though
they don't deliver you looking even for
a bottle of wine or summer beer throw in
a pack of smokes if that's your thing no
problem they will do anything for you
and it's so freakin convenient I cannot
endorse post mates enough and as they
say is your new long-term munchies booty
call although a parent item went in yeah
don't try anything on your driver I
don't think that's what that means
I love posts mates so much just give it
a shot and you're gonna see how freaking
incredible and convenient and
mind-blowing this app is for limited
time post mates is giving you $100 of
free delivery credit so you get to try
it for the first 7 days $100 free
delivery credit give it a shot you got
nothing to lose
start your free deliveries download the
app today and use code h3 that's code h3
for $100 a free delivery credit for the
next 7 days save the hassle get the food
you love fast at post mates with code h3
I love this app please try it out
appreciate you I love the Dollar Shave
Club has everything I need to look feel
and smell my very best what I love the
most is that I never have to go to the
store
that's because Dollar Shave Club
delivers everything I need right to my
dang door and to they keep me fully
stocked and what I use so I don't ever
out here's how it works Dollar Shave
Club has everything you need to get
ready no matter what you're getting
ready for they got you covered head to
toe for the hair your skin your face you
name it they've got it and they have
this new program where they
automatically keep you stocked up on the
products you use you determine what you
want and when you want it and it shows
up right at your door from once a month
to once every six months you decide
that's what I love and let me tell you
they got this new shampoo out that is a
beautiful perfectly balanced it's got
this beautiful smell it keeps my hair
nice and lush unfortunately I have no
hair but before when I did have hair
that little poof mohawk in the middle
was so lush and beautiful and smelled
like a dream
fortunately it did not look good so I
had to axe it out but the smell and the
feel unbelievable plus with their
handsome discount the more you buy the
more you save so right now they got a
bunch of starter sets you can try for
just five dollars there you find that
deal in the grocery store like their
shower starter set which includes the
shampoo after that the restock box gets
shipped regular sized products at
regular price so what are you waiting
for get your starter set now for just
five dollars at Dollar Shave Club com /h
3 that's a Dollar Shave Club com /h 3
guys get started today for just 5
dollars if you are in the market for a
watch now is the perfect time to head on
over to Vince cero because they're
having an epic pre Black Friday sale
that's right the biggest site-wide sale
of the year my dudes the holiday can be
stressful enough without having to worry
about breaking the bank Ben Sira watches
is taking the hassle out of holiday
shopping by having an epic pre Black
Friday sale no matter who you're
shopping for you can get them a luxury
beautiful timepiece that they will love
long after the holiday season is over as
ELA is beautifully modeling for you here
and the best part is you can get it
early their mission is to create
compelling luxury timepieces with
impeccable craftsmanship to inspire as
many people as possible to elevate their
game
and ultimately to lift her the legacy
dude my dude you're gonna live a legacy
with this watch holy smokes
we learned that luxury is a process is
not about specs it's not about price
it's about marketing I
it's not about marketing items to be
thrown around it's a matter of attention
to detail and a step-by-step process to
craft every product and especially it's
about legacy they're big on legacy we
wanted to offer a watch it was able to
stand out get noticed and set yourself
apart and not conform and at an
accessible price their watches have a
distinct look a quality feel this watch
will get you noticed and that I
mentioned legacy Oh able to provide the
look and feel of bold luxury watches at
ten times the price by selling directly
to the consumer so if you want to
capitalize on this attack Black Friday
sale best prices of the year head on
over to Vince era watches calm slash h3
sale or click the link in the
description it's happening right now and
these offers will not last long and let
me let me be frank your legacy won't
last long either unless you get this
watch thank you welcome back my black
friday dudes
speaking of black friday ela has put
together a segment of Black Friday deals
that nobody wants and nobody cares about
Neela I'm very excited you know why
don't we switch spots so I prefer a few
control though okay no good what do you
think too close yeah I guess whoa this
is weird man
Ethan you might be interested it's only
lower price right now what's the
discount lower price of it's the URL you
have to select
besides I think I can tell you it's
about five dollars off
well that's thrilling oh yeah so there
you have it I like what the ABS are just
kind of built into it
sure yeah you need this is called men a
waist trainer vest for weight oh it's
for weight loss like you could wear it
is this for instant weight lost
well instantly gives you abs by just
kind of faking weight loss high heel
print corset body shaper oh it's a body
shaper zipper sauna tank top workout
shirt go up to images whoa the fire
alright well that's actually got good
review it's caught it's in the category
of sauna suits talked about you have to
show that picture it's a great reality
versus expectation right but wait is it
what is the purpose of it just just slim
look slimmer oh he says no doubt about
it it makes me sweat more than usual
well that's because you have a super
tight and allow you to exercise shame on
vendor one start well either way this
can be yours for five dollars off a
thrilling thrilling savings here today
I'm lying Friday we're not hating here
that's right you look not hating next is
a horn horn horn incredible also very
well reviewed a well ways the sale price
this was featured on their Black Friday
so it's not even don't even save any
money
for this genuine oxhorn well this was
featured maybe all right well we go
next one what do we got tell me about it
Norsemen
12-inch authentic oxhorn drinking
genuine leather mmm-hmm and with the
stand I guess it's on sale but we don't
know for how much so hurry while
supplies last
exactly he's exciting wish we had some
exciting music to play oh man now then
wrap it up Zack
give us some thrilling music cuz timing
whoa that thing probably gets so dirty
so quick my greasy hands on that okay
we've got a Oh grim our wait is that
world of warcraft
what is Oh grim are is that a world of
warcraft reference you guys oka Mar is
the capital of the the Horde so yes oh
so we have a World of Warcraft merch on
sale today
I think it's spelled differently though
o remark I don't think that's wrong you
know what it's on sale today on this
Black Friday get it while supplies last
it's our it's our more Algrim our winter
warm faux wool steering wheel cover with
handbrake Oh
the handbrake cover comes so you can
match yes if you are wondering the
carpet doesn't match the drapes that's
right
this could be dangerous
yes sir you live as Overmars always in
constant threat of invasion so is your
safety in this car but nice stuff it's
probably the best offer at the Dollar
Tree everything is actually a dollar for
once incredible sales Black Friday calm
that's right
wait are you saying that stuff at the
Dollar Tree isn't always a dollar
that's right Dan what it's a loophole a
gray area that somehow they managed to
find that's right advertised well I feel
like inflation's got to the point where
now they just think if it's on $1 clean
like it was 1 2 3 then they're like it's
multiple of $1 but today only today the
Dollar Tree is actually just $1 folks
incredible savings this deal went live
one month ago it says hurry while
supplies last what a thrill it is to
save on this Black Friday and you don't
CVS Black Friday incredible savings 99
cents but hurry while supplies last you
have to were lined up at 3 a.m. to get
these incredible patented Goong for 99
cents yes indeed last but not least you
need to upgrade your browser the one
item we all need Wow Garth Brooks the
anthology live part 3 Wow part 3 is on
sale today only from 39 $30 to $17 the
Impala ecology part 3 let's get physical
while doing music I'm gonna discs is
that it looks like five dancing Kraske
enough steel hive yes Garth Brooks I
want to be cool I want to be slick
that's right head on over to Walmart /ip
slash scarf - Brooks dark anthology -
live - bar 7 3 Ford / - 2 9 6 7 5 8 9 5
while supplies last
that's it ok
[Laughter]
[Applause]
incredible I think we may have sold a
couple Garth broken thaller G books I'm
buying right now it's like stop life
switching it's just on the longshot he's
buying all these anthologies my resale
these ideal like that so here's a story
that I absolutely love dude wants to
legally change his age why does he want
to legally change his age from 69 to 49
because it will help him get more dates
on tinder understandable at 69 69 that's
right here we have it here's a video
about it as a legend man you just trying
to [ __ ] he's like dude nobody wants to
[ __ ] a 69 year old but my dick I got a
49 year old dick my purse still 69 we
can 69 but I'm 49 and I feel I suffer
under my age because I'm much more
younger than my 68 so when I ask for a
mortgage for example they say it's
impossible if I go on tinder you know
then I get I never thought about it that
you can't get a mortgage at all age
because you'll die before you can pay it
off isn't that gnarly yeah this guy he's
49 you know like did you want to
mortgage your 69 ish I'll give you five
years tops the mortgage bankers like you
want a mortgage I'll give you five
thirty year for from 68 a 69 when the
woman are there and when I'm on tinder
you know the then they say okay then you
can lie for your age you say you're 49 I
don't want to I I want to be myself so
don't force me to lie but when I am
really 49 again
I will have a baby again I will buy a
new car again I will paint my house
again I going outside and I invest my
money again because now I'm old man you
know I have to save my money to give to
my kids so they can live but if I have
that age again I've hope again
I'm new again and there the whole future
is there for me again all right ironclad
logic right there so I wanted to say
well I know there's been a lot of debate
about changing genders and this kind of
whole thing and that gender is a
construct the social construct and
people changing sexes all this you know
we can debate about we can debate about
gender roles and that old things time
however I think is indisputable at least
right now as far as we all know time is
a linear fact I don't think we're
trapped time-traveling yet he's like
described himself as a young god yes he
did you know he said a 69 year old he's
a positivity guru he says he does not
feel his age and has started a battle to
make himself legally twenty years
younger on the grounds that he's being
discriminated on dating apps doctors
told him his body was that of a 45 year
old man and he described himself as a
young god yes the judge expressed
skepticism but also noted that changing
the sex on a birth certificate as a
transgender people have the right to do
that which was once impossible is now
allowed changed under people around the
world have fought long battles the right
to change their birth certificates to
match their gender identity where this
is permitted the legal requirements vary
and the Netherlands transgender people
need a statement from an expert
affirming that they have a permanent
conviction that their gender does not
match what is on their birth certificate
and that they understand the
repercussion of their decision but again
here you know that's gender is a kind of
abstract idea in a sense that it's not a
physical the idea
here we're talking about age I mean we
can't debate age right mmm but
apparently the judge is actually it's
unlikely to happen but the judge is like
open-minded about it I mean what what
what is our world be when people decide
their own age like a 13 year old or like
a 18 or being like I'm 20 I am actually
21 an emotional age did what's right
imagine I you know I like he oh he
almost just talks that if he was able to
change his age to like 45 that he'd be
like he's like my dick will work again
yeah and like say it will like magically
like actually reverse his age I can get
a mortgage my dick will work there you
have it
what do you think you that's a weird one
he looks pretty good for 69 I'll give
him that
yeah maybe he is a young God but he
should embrace hmm I think his problems
yeah yeah dude that's 20 years and once
you're that old every decade is like hit
you harder than the last I think he's
just like I don't want to [ __ ] I don't
want to [ __ ] 69 year olds he's looking
on tinners all these old ladies he's
like I want to [ __ ] these hot-ass 49
year old mm-hmm he's 4 have you seen
these 49 year olds they're bangin
they're hot as hell my dick will work
like it only changed my age you think he
really believes it or is he is he full
of [ __ ]
well you had mentioned Dan that it was
some it's hard to say all the articles
I've read it seemed to take it very
seriously but you said that you had read
some
that's some kind of protest yeah I
thought I had seen somewhere that he's
he's trying to yeah I mean like you you
brought up the whole gender issue thing
I think he maybe is trying to make a
point about that but yeah I mean like
you said I mean obviously it's pretty
[ __ ] a different yeah you know I see
people always trying to make this play
are you really gonna compare that to a
gender issue well one is like measurably
wrong like okay you're but people say oh
you're born with the dick that makes you
man but still you can identify more as a
female and so there's a debate to be had
and some empathy and understanding and
you can't physically change your sex you
can remove your penis and surgically
implant of Aegina and you can assume the
identity of a female and you can be born
with certain genitalia but it's kind of
like in the middle what do you what do
you mean like a pin you can be both like
I inverted you there are some people
that are born with both correct me if
I'm wrong then but wasn't Jamie Lee
Curtis born with both a vagina and a
penis what I swear I swear look it up
I'll look it up Jamie Lee Curtis super
famous she was like a babe she was like
one of the hottest babes in the 90s let
me make sure I'm saying her name right
yeah that's her I think she was born
with a with both a penis and a vagina
that appears to just be an urban legend
are you kidding me idiot look again
double-check that well I I just went to
Snopes there they're faulting it just
flat out so that we fat check that yeah
I evidently there's a reason you thought
that though cuz this is like a thing
yeah but no that's lust uh this is not
true I had never why would people think
that about it but it's that a real thing
then because now I'm questioning if
that's even oh well yeah what what ELA
was just describing absolutely is the
thing sometimes you know when a baby is
born it's it's sort of ambiguous and
it's sort of
doctor just kind of makes a call so that
is very what does it mean a doctor just
makes a call can happen wait no no no no
I got understand this the doctor makes a
call
so is he doing something to the baby or
is he just writing male or female on the
birth certificate is that the latter
yeah and so what if the baby has a penis
and he's written down as female I I mean
I don't know the specifics of it but I
do know that this is I mean this
obviously this is not super common this
is wait I'm just really actually curious
about the medic can you guys look into
that yeah no I'm curious let's look into
that
we're so sidetracked but now I'm just
fascinated so baby can be born with like
either and they cannot and the doctor
can't tell the genitalia intersexuality
occurs whenever human being has both
male and female physical characteristics
contrary to the meats and they do not
have two sets of genitals mmm they often
have ambiguous genital structures not
readily identifiable was clitoris or
penis or you know so it's somewhere in
the middle why but that means that they
have like a like a vaginal like they
have a vagina like an entrance and like
a little penis - does that mean they
could actually [ __ ] themselves I don't
know just I know I know you're just
curious but yeah I'm asking what people
are thinking or words we should have
knowledge I'm just I'm still reading I
don't wanna I don't wanna may still
present this at all okay but anyway well
regardless of regardless Jamie Lee
Curtis is not we have definitely cleared
that one up so damn but it can be like
[Music]
well at any rate it says that you can go
and like people can go on long periods
of their lives without knowing that
there were intersex what and then they
like grow out of it no just I think just
when you're a kid I mean you're not
literally seeing other people you don't
know that you're different I'm curious
to see what that looks like obviously I
can't show that yeah no but I am cured
that is why are you seeing pictures no
I'm just trying to read about it but
that's why the gender issues well even
with no regardless of that it's such a
stupid well people have been making
these arguments for so long people have
been saying it about homosexuality first
they say oh if two dudes can [ __ ] each
other or marry each other then what then
one can we start marrying animals yeah
that's and bla it's it's just so weak
it's so lame like and first of all
animals cannot consent mmm-hmm you know
people people always ask me can vegans
take a can they can you come in a vegans
mouth people are always asking you that
people always ask me that
but I would say yes you can come in a
vegans mouth and I'll tell you why
because a human can consent to give you
their semen and I assure you that it
will be given with much pleasure if my
experience is any indication of that but
animals cannot consent to give you their
we might write down and I'm representing
this rate you're a vegetarian well yeah
animals cannot consent to allowing you
to kill them all right guess you're
talking more about like dairy or eggs or
something like this yes correct so so
semen is vegan if you have the consent
of the person did you send me a link you
want me to read this so back to that
previous thing I just want to correct
that it could look like a male or female
genitalia doesn't look weird necessarily
but you're homeless could be oh like you
could have the other hormones or
something that's the only during puberty
interesting you'll feel different
there's a lot of degrees my screen I'm
looking up inner inner sex genitals damn
okay in
but they said that it happened actually
a lot more than people realize
one in 100 people in the US right I
didn't want that's what I had heard - I
didn't want to say it just off the top
my head and be wrong but yeah it's it's
much more common than here's a picture
of uh I've typed in ER six genitals and
here's a picture Jamie Lee Curtis
[Laughter]
they're definitely appeared I guess that
was an urban legend that existed because
many articles came up about it when I
googled it so I don't know had never
heard that before it's just I heard that
like as like a fact yeah false false
let's see here yes is she she's a she
but regardless I find that that argument
very listen homosexuals transsexuals
they're people I just don't understand
the whole this whole campaign of like
trying to why are why are you even
trying to contradict them just let them
live their live like you know what I
mean I mean obviously some of them are
pretty aggressive and annoying but if
someone's just like hey I'm transgender
I don't see that being an argument you
know but again if this guy is doing it
as a protest I think it's very very very
weak because time is measured my dude
you have been on this earth for 69 years
right and unless I missed a memo we do
not have time trouble yet and so time as
I know it is not yet in dispute
sexuality however is somewhat of an
abstract concept I know that there are
male and female genitals so there is
that concreteness of biological sex but
I guess what the trans people got is
gender which is which is different and
and and like we just said I mean even
the even the biological aspect isn't
always known greater I mean it
definitely is a
completely different beast so if he is
trying to do this to make a point it's
it's a pretty weak argument it's a weak
argument and also it's I mean dude just
just [ __ ] those old ladies do you like
Kyle Kyle the people champ now the
cougar champs got no problem man he gets
and he takes it for all of us he's a
young man and you're trying to lie on
tinder about your age so you can [ __ ]
some 49 year old cute little cuties
young cuties mm-hmm it's [ __ ] up man
it's [ __ ] up it's just not right there
you have it
HT podcast spring knowledge mm-hmm this
is a wild story
so this American missionary who's trying
to spread the word of God goes to a
there's an island in in India that is
blocked off from all u of humanity and
this tribe has lived there in isolation
for fifty five thousand years some
people estimate and the Indian
government protects this island because
well first of all I think there's
something beautiful about they don't
want any they don't wash in yeah and and
I think there's something beautiful
about conserving that and just letting
them live in peace there's been people
who have attempted to go there and
they've always reacted violently as I
guess I was reading an article that the
British went to the island early during
their colonial days and like decimated
the population of the island and since
then their original numbers have been
decimated and now they're still just a
small fraction of what the original
population was and they're very guarded
justifiably from outsiders and so this
American missionary goes to India we
pulled this article he writes that he's
going there for tourism but his real
purpose is that he wants to spread the
message of Jesus against the law
preventing India prohibits prohibits
visitors and well he was killed
by the natives yeah whoops here let's
see here
John is said to have died in a hail of
arrows as he set foot on North Sentinel
Sentinel island part of the Indian
controlled islands in the Bay of Bengal
people who live there are one of the few
tribes completely cut off from the rest
of the world and have previously fired
at outsiders the media here is really
incredible these people are fascinating
like here's someone off the coast here's
the tribe yeah like when they see people
off the coast they stand guard on the
beach they're [ __ ] it's amazing what
a trip it's like really uh here's the
island right here it's a really
beautiful little cut of land which is
incredible fifty-five thousand years
they've been there Indian police
confirmed the death and said local
electronic engineers simply his name was
Alexander he had locals and five
fishermen took him out to the island
illegally he hired fishing guys to get
close and he kayaks to the island from
the boat here's some more footage of
them and this was like a known thing
that they were hostile oh yes prohibited
by the Indian government they're my own
hot there
well the fishermen knew that too and
actually they're under arrest now oh wow
oh right because they broke the law
taking him there he was attacked by
arrows but continued walking I'm not the
fisherman saw the tribals trying to rope
oh my god the fisherman saw the tribals
tying a rope around his neck and
dragging his body they were scared and
fled but returned next morning to find
his body on the seashore [ __ ] crazy
the people are banned from getting
within three miles of the island
the island with an estimated population
of between 40 and 200 Wow that's not a
lot mm-hmm
apparently there used to be thousands of
them and said to be at risk of death if
they have contact with outsiders because
they have no immunity to common diseases
like flu and measles so this guy out
there trying to give them God trying to
give him a little taste of Jesus could
actually end up decimate wiping them out
the final I mean I'm not happy the guy
died but it's like yeah you got you got
what well you know I mean the guy went
looking for Jesus and he found him I
[Music]
don't hey I'm thinking all he may have
taken the whole visions what he's like
hey he sees him in the afterlife like
hey I saved you all we made it we made
it you guys on the evening of 14
November the group of six pretending to
be fishing evaded the patrolling police
Coast Guard and navy ships reaching the
island at midnight before mr.chu kayak
to the island in the morning
police said the fisherman agreed a time
and place to meet each other near the
island on the morning of 17th November
they saw a dead person being buried at
the shore which from the silhouette of
the body clothing and circumstance
appeared to be the body of John Allen
chew this is an iconic photograph taken
from a helicopter after the 2004 tsunami
which apparently they somehow survived
like this huge tsunami yeah this guy is
shooting a bone arrow at a helicopter
because they're just so unacquainted
with the outside world I can't imagine
what they would think what would you
even think yeah yeah be terrifying some
gnarly bird probably
in a situation like this too I mean what
what was the plan I mean how are you
gonna you can't just give them Bibles
they don't speak English to explore any
he could be the one guy that could have
rich to them I think so the thing about
these missionaries they believe that it
comes from a good place even though it's
insane as they think that the best thing
you can do for another person is give
them Christianity because they'll die in
internal torment if she's trying to save
their soul right so to him he's like
this is like I'm gonna save these guys
from and from eternal torment they never
even got the word of Jesus Christ so how
are they supposed to get saved and so he
goes out there with the purest of
intentions but I mean I will say for him
at least he didn't [ __ ] a kid so there
is some thing nice to say about him
after all it's a pretty wild story
though going alone - I mean he clearly
he knew what he was getting stuff into
because he hired a black yeah a black
market uh illegal fishermen to ride his
ass there in kayak and of corn where I
read there was hails of arrows coming at
him he continued to walk with Bible on
hand
did it say that it yeah it's it huh you
want me to go back I'll read that [ __ ]
I'll read the hell out of that [ __ ]
again Mel Gibson can make a movie about
this guy and in the movie the natives
are Jews of course here it says
uh he was attacked by arrows but
continued walking the fisherman said
pressing forward yeah a little
Braveheart moment so there you have it
pretty wild man Z American he's American
yes what do you think about that I mean
yeah it says John loved people and he
loved Jesus he was willing to give his
life to share Jesus with the people and
North Sentinel island ever since high
school John wanted to go to that Island
to share Jesus with distinct indigenous
people or since high school there's like
a long term project yeah I mean it's
again I know there's kind of terrible to
say but it's really hard to sympathize
with this guy it's like you knew you
knew exactly what you were getting
yourself into
you know interesting story
at what point it's like you can go to
church and all that but at what point at
what point does religion become insane
like you can believe in but his defining
characteristic is that he loved the God
and that his whole life was to go it's
it seems like a suicide they are a
little bit yeah mm-hmm he's a martyr
right it wasn't more hmm you know God
loves martyrs so there you have it
like you said though I mean the point
where it it drips into yeah it's just
[ __ ] up is the there is the high
likelihood that you're gonna infect all
these people with measles or smallpox or
something well that's wipe them out it's
like that's a nice kind of you're kind
of you kind of [ __ ] up at that ball
hmm well he's like my only I just wanted
to get them a Bible now if they all die
it's okay right they're safe
I don't think so dude they're all safe
now I don't know little bit of arrogance
a little bit but I feel bad for the guy
I wish him all the best in the afterlife
I hope he is received well by God and
that he says you did my work and you
saved those savages you know I mean my
god they've got bows and arrows they
need Bibles and we need to get them job
so that they can pay their 15% Tiff's
teeth how do you say that when this high
tithe we need to get those savages
paying tithe right now because you know
that God don't run on faith you run on
money all right what's next well we got
a lot of lot of windows open you know
speaking of stories that I don't know
how to feel about it - there was another
one 95 year old Nazi deported to Germany
and I found this such a fascinating
story because on one hand he had not
seeing which we all hate but he's like
this 95 year old guy who's being
deported to Germany he's lived here for
70 years he's 95 here is in the u.s.
yeah in the United States huh 1949 and
Germany doesn't want him either
they're like he's not a city we don't
[ __ ] want this Nazi but he's so old
and frail well let me watch the video
over night of a New York man officials
are calling the last surviving not
they've got him rolling a great jacket
wonder what the hell it could take out a
he could guess a Jew at any minute
1949
in his past as an armed guard and oh
thank you he was stripped of his
citizenship years ago but he remained
here in the US that is until now Mary is
here with the story Tara good morning
good morning Polly Polly has been living
in the shadows for decades am an
authority say is the last known
surviving Nazi collaborator on US soil
until now living in Queens New York his
presence they are bringing on years of
outrage from the surrounding community
but this morning he's been deported to
Germany at the direct order of President
Tremblay ABC News was there exclusively
as ice agents wheeled and 95 died wait
that's it the German what you can't get
even get on a plane at 95 I mean that
guy is gonna knock last long
well Germany doesn't know what to do
with him either but I get the premises
that he's a Nazi and he doesn't even the
guy deserves no dignity or comfort or
anything right that's I guess the
premise they sent ice out there for
Christ's sake to wrap him up and throw
him in a airplane well here listen to
Justin Bieber sir do you have any
comment do you have any comment on
Ariana Grande's breakup with Pete Pete
Davidson so are you a Nazi sir have you
heard thank you next you have any
comment sir Jerry Seinfeld is them one
of the most rich Jews have you seen his
stand-up are you fan of Jerry Seinfeld
sir
can I get a can I get a remark he's uh
looks like he's dead sir sir are you fan
of Seinfeld or Larry David have you seen
Seinfeld the show sir loved it
I mean it's obviously a theater it's
like a show because nothing's really at
stake here mmm
it's just yeah it's just state man it's
a theatrical it's fair it's very much
just for show well what'd you learn
later in the stories that he was just a
guard I don't know what his involvement
was necessarily and and and the
execution of of people during the
Holocaust who use a guard at one of the
death camps though right yes he was and
he oh yeah well here the story continues
to explain but the real question is what
does he think about the full house
remake finally being deported for his
alleged role as an armed guard at a Nazi
death camp bowling decades after his
alleged involvement
Justice Department investigators say
poster have you seen b-movie any regrets
that's complicit in the deaths of
thousands of Jews during World War two
authorities say poly lied to immigration
officials when he first entered the u.s.
in 1949 and it wasn't until 2003 that he
was exposed as an alleged war criminal
and stripped of his US citizenship
anything you'd like to say sir anything
the lead investigators think sir have
you seen Frazier do you know that phrase
is run by Jews do you have any remark
this footage is so weird carrying him
like that
I'm confused about the straitjacket
situation yeah this trade you all they
see a clear and imminent threat
in 2004 what do you think about Krusty
being a juicer have you seen the
Simpsons Krusty was a Jew in the Simpson
yeah his dad was a rabbi I'm in deep I
got Simpsons lore four days during a
single nightmarish day in November 1943
all of the more than 6,000 prisoners of
the Nazi camp that yakky Polly had
guarded were systematically butchered a
judge ordered him deported in 2005 but
no country would take him for years
protesters gathered outside his home in
Queens demanding action members of
Congress imploring President Trump to
finish what was started to send a
message the entire world that the United
States stands firmly against
anti-semitism bigotry and hatred the
deportation drawing rare praise for
Trump from top Democrats he's a war
criminal he didn't deserve to live in
the United States he doesn't deserve to
die in the United States place of
freedom inequality where we respect each
other's difference sources tell ABC News
the president became fixated on the case
or during his new ambassador to Germany
Richard Grinnell to make Polly's and
deportation a top priority after being
sworn in it's unclear what's next for
him he's being detained by the German
government but they're still evaluating
his legal status since they don't
consider him to be a German citizen so
deported overnight future to be
determined in Germany exactly how about
that that's a weird one it's a weird one
I mean he's a Nazi [ __ ]
clearly but he's also 95 years old you
know what would you do I mean I don't
know how to feel about it I'm AB
ambivalent I just don't see at this
point what's the point of doing this
yeah they should just throw him in a
hole I mean prison sounds like no just a
hole sounds like since it took this long
for them to report him and Germany
doesn't want him either he basically is
probably just gonna spend the rest of
his life in in a camp
Roenick yeah that is kind of a beautiful
thing let's put him in a camp I'm okay
with Rico
make him watch B movie for all of
eternity
Jerry Seinfeld presents this speeds up
every time it says B yeah let's hop on
over to fan submissions guys if you have
submissions for us questions videos
suggestions anything at all please drop
us a line at podcast at h3h3 productions
comm today we have an email from Michi
guys big fan of the show oh this is
sorry I'm getting ahead of myself you
want to watch the CEO of Pappajohn now
let's give this fan finishes your boy
Mitchie says I think honestly ping and
the sink is a superior method than using
a urinal pros you can save up to 5
litres of water because you don't have
to flush you can wash your hands while
you're doing it I don't understand don't
don't you finish pain before you wash
your hands otherwise what's the point
none of this makes sense why are you
washing our hands while you're paying
that's you're not done with the act the
sink doesn't have you ever thought about
you haven't thought about this but I
wash my hands before I pee because I
don't want to get my dick dirty mm-hmm
right except because the dick is kind of
a holy it's my temple it's a it's a
quarantine down there the sink doesn't
really get dirty because you are
cleaning it up while your pain literally
impossible to miss so you don't have to
worry about cleaning up or even putting
toilet seat up splash is something that
I'm concerned about this is not cleaning
it up but if you're peeing in a sink
there's a little drops of urine all over
the place standing upright cons you have
to properly clean the sink once a week
that's disgusting bro once a week if
somebody walks in on you you are gonna
get kicked out of their house well I
disagree with the premise of peeing in
the sink but I found a subreddit called
sink pisser's
Oh No which is singularly as a whole
subculture yeah it's a whole community
dedicated to the glory of ping in a sink
and from the sidebar it says don't ask
yourself what the world needs ask
yourself what makes you come alive and
go do that
because what the world needs is people
who have come alive he was talking about
pissing in the sink one pea is sterile
two sinks are unsterile three people
spit in the sink every day and
occasionally vomit there
I don't pee in my friends seek
I don't pee in the kitchen sink I run
the water while I pee I never [ __ ] in
the sink well that's a good thank God I
don't pee in the sink when there are
urals nearby
I don't pee in the tub unless I'm
showering in it if I notice that any pee
has missed the drain I wipe it down well
the the pee is sterile thing that's I
believe that's [ __ ] i I know that
gets repeated all you look that up
because I recently saw an article saying
that P is not actually sterile way he's
gross okay it's gross we can all agree
although I've seen some porns where the
people don't think it's gross sure you
can find everything urine is not stale
there's nail art stair
it could be stale I suppose but it's not
sterile I keep the water running after I
finish peeing a peeing in the sink
although more readily accomplished by
males is not in any way limited to the
male sex now here's one of the pulse
that I looked at that really horrified
me okay which goes against the tenets of
Peaks
if this goes against the tenants of sink
piers and this is the fourth highest
rated post on the subreddit so a
different kind of mile-high club the
dude is peeing in the sink and an
airplane the toilet right there this has
got to be ironic like well this is
people for real I think it is for real
Oh although it's hard to save because
the post under it says heavy breathing
and it's
picture of a sink - toilet gang owned
you see that one yeah
imagine pissing that's one sink pisser
masterrace what is this
imagine ping but you have to flush it
this meme was made by sink pee gang well
there you have it so I I think you
should use a toilet if you're asking me
I think you should use a toilet
you know you may enjoy it and I'm I've
peed in a sink before I'm not gonna lie
ok I've done it but I don't I've not
asked why I think it was possibly that
the where'd you think I think it must
have been first when I was a kid just
out of curiosity see if you could do it
and then another time probably I don't
remember if it was with you ela or a
different girlfriend but we were both in
the bathroom at a time and she was on
the toilet and I peed in the sink they
may have been with you you remember
something like that
yeah I think it was you it was a long
[ __ ] time ago that must have been
like so long ago now boy like super
drunk yeah I think we were drunk I think
it was like a art gallery and we were
drinking wine or some [ __ ] but
regardless we were drunk but the point
is that yeah we weren't thinking right
it's not like something we would do no
it's not Bailey and I can die was I
cleaned up I didn't splash but I also
I'm just saying a splash could happen
splash does happen and all I'm saying is
that we've live it to it brush next to
the thing
there was no toothbrushes next to the
sink no I'm saying about this guy oh
yeah well you know they say that there's
poop particles found on most tooth
brushing are you saying I'm telling you
look it up damn the more fact-checking
who particles found on most toothbrushes
but I think that life is complicated
enough you don't need to be peeing and
sinks looking over your shoulder try
explaining that to a you know a new date
or a family member are god forbid anyone
I mean yeah the the poop thing is
verified I think it looks like thank you
who doesn't know their [ __ ] now read me
an excerpt Anna oh well it says your
toothbrush is home to plaque blood and
even fecal matter yes you're probably
scrubbing poop particles all over your
pearly whites there was a study in 2012
this the sink pisser is listening or
like so that's the problem right I say
don't pee in the sink for Christ's sake
man get your [ __ ] together Chris Donahue
what up h3 fairly popular men's style
video made a video about youtubers with
black hair styles and to no surprise
Thank You Ethan was one of the people he
talked about here we go buckle up I'm
ready to get pissed I mean that was love
but he looks like an elf ears are a
little pointed it's true it's like the
hair everything he's got going on he's
very hand is very elf handsome elf chic
style
it's a earrings too he's a little bit of
a swashbuckler you know pirates wore
gold earrings to pay for their funeral
is that real Dan can we fact check that
I'm on it
legend has it all the Pirates wore gold
earrings so that if they died in combat
the earring could be used to pay for
their funeral is that fascinating yeah
well I'm a wealth of knowledge and
Dana's fact-checking me as we speak
meanwhile but could be so much better is
mr. Ethan Klein even has incredibly
thick coarse curly hair he's gone short
he's gone long he's gone through that I
absolutely love
these girls are hot dude Legolas who
wouldn't [ __ ] the show Legolas
it's not the blonde yeah you know you
[ __ ] the [ __ ] Legolas yeah you would you
know who Legolas is dating Katy Perry oh
really yeah Wow it's getting some
[ __ ] premium that's what I meant by
elf now that I found out you like my
content giving it now the incredible
thing about Ethan his hair is so crazy
thick it's crazy curly one of the
problems with thick like the ball miss
hairstylist I would totally hire him to
be my hair stylist hair is that if you
don't understand it if you don't nurture
it and love it and get a hair stylist
that understands how to cut it they can
be a disaster but it could be better
like this with the right product that's
got it okay what's happening here what
happened here Dan [ __ ] but certainly not
least the fourth popular you would be
better like this with the right prop we
see that dan what is it what the [ __ ] is
that shot it's just the screen got super
small can you help me out here good I'm
you think I think so but how did could
he miss that
what the hell YouTube help me out could
be better like this with the right there
what is this mm-hmm are you seeing this
Dan yeah I'm seeing it I not just baked
into his video and he just [ __ ] up I
mean it's just so strange but I've got
some film here you think I could pull
that look off yellow I think you could
but you wouldn't take some work that
guy's got like wax in his hair you know
what I mean either I draw the line at
wax mm-hmm but that's hot hair I mean
that hair is [ __ ] maybe it's just
they can rock it I think it's just that
he's very attractive and it looks like I
look good on that guy look I could have
like pubic hair and look pretty good I
want to [ __ ] this guy's what I'm saying
this hair come on dawg there's no way in
hell I'm selling
here like that I mean I'm not doing that
he's got a fade and like a little
pompadour curl I mean dude imagine a
chubby guy like me who dresses in like
elastic waist shorts walking off the
haircut like that
curly luscious locks of amazing come on
dude I am there's no way I'm styling my
hair like that what do you think you
look no no you like my hair the way it
is yeah I like that we Herman yeah girl
let's go jerk off in movie theater like
this
Ethan should go see a stylist who
understands curly hair he might need
some type of relaxation treatment just
to take a little bit of the curl out of
the hair it's gonna relax the curl a
little bit more in terms of product he
could probably get away with the Pete
and Pedro cream which is a leave-in
conditioner or the bean Pedro paste if
he's looking forward you're sure this
guy's this guy's embed Ramon oh wow
calls it the question everything he says
is Brandon he's in their pocket you
think it's a little bit of shine
gentlemen if you are not sure what well
there you have it I think you should go
for a man well I'm gonna have to wait
like a year before his long again but
when that happens I'm gonna ask your boy
for some Pete and Pedro mm-hmm whenever
it was he so on this one comes from
James hey my name is James I'm from the
UK and a level-10 vapor Dan will know
what I mean my little sick that's a hot
that's a high level is that good oh yeah
and my local shop I found what I swear
is a budget hunk version of Ethan maybe
it's just me let's see
the vape juice there what happened here
he continues just thought you should
know what kind of taste like [ __ ]
there was a lineman on lime flavor
available to keep doing what you're
doing and congrats on the baby it
definitely looks like a budget it looks
like animation yeah answer me
well you know if you're gonna use my
likeness for a babe flavor at least make
a nice one you know
yeah that's bogus that it's a terrible
flavor I wonder what it sells for on
Black Friday if I can get this on
discount probably always on discount I'm
gonna try and track some down I want
smoky babe yeah so there you have it
that is all we've got today I hope you
all have a wonderful Thanksgiving
weekend I'll be a lot of great
Thanksgiving thanks for joining us here
today
next Friday we've got bill words finally
coming in super excited to have him oh
yeah Jack and Eric is that the week
after Dan I believe so the boys are back
in town the week after that and I'm
super excited to meet bill words I'm
such a huge fan we're all very and he's
such a mysterious guy - he's just so
creative an interesting dude so if you
have questions or anything you'd like to
ask him or you want to tell me anything
about him head on over to the subreddit
there's a thread there where you can
submit a lot of great questions in there
already - thank you everybody that's
great thanks for participating that so
make sure to tune in a week from today
for Bill warts meanwhile have an awesome
weekend and we love you and wish you all
the very frickin best thanks for
watching bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]